would you like some help I'm gonna be
yep you know I don't know yeah hey
everybody I'm Kelsey and today I'm
trying the 100 good deed challenge so
it's almost State Farm's 100th
anniversary and to celebrate they're
challenging themselves to do 100 acts of
good so I thought why don't I try to do
100 acts of good but this time all in
one day I oftentimes find that the more
I'm trying to cheer other people up the
more cheerful I becomes one small thing
can really uplift someone else's day
challenge tag so I'm gonna just pay for
the next four orders it might will be
like you know this together right
thank you
yeah Oh have a good one
I'm ready to go do more we got only
limited time so
the rooms are kind of wet
[Music]
so talks are super important and we have
a big dog lover and so we're giving this
shelter dog a walk and I'm also going to
try to like find this stalker forever
home what is over there
nothing same I also get distracted by
nothing I really like your hat and your
whole outfit it's a vibe I really like
your eye makeup it's just like really
pretty oh you're welcome
thanks have a good day you too I like
your earrings there sir here you two at
once can't stop won't stop another great
way of showing people you care is by
ordering them surprise pizza I completed
the 100 good deeds challenge I never
doubted myself for a minute there pat on
the back to me sometimes I can get
caught up in like the doing big things
and not thinking you know that I don't
always think small and the little things
actually really did add up to big smiles
I know that was really cheesy but it was
very true
I definitely feel more connected to my
neighborhood for sure Thank You State
Farm for inspiring me to do more good
this holiday season and inspiring the
rest of us hopefully to
[Music]